what do you think of the relationship
that we should have with our inner
critic I mean I think it's it's
interesting Walt Disney had three
different rooms so he had a room to be
creative right just come up with ideas
no bad ideas great other than some of
the anti-Semitism anyway so he's got his
ideas room and then he's got his um he's
got his management room well how how do
we make those room how do we make those
ideas happen how are we going to make
that stuff happen and then he had
another room for criticism
and I think we should sort of think
about the inner critic like that the
idea of going if you're trying to do
something creative don't let the critic
in too
soon wait until you've had the whole
idea wait until you've let the
management get involved a little bit
wait until you've tried to write the
whole joke and ComEd it from a few
different angles and tried it twice
before you critic you criticize it and
Outsourcing your critic I think is it's
smart I mean comedy does it with the
audience really they make the decision
as to what the show is they do the
editing for
me so you got a much better relationship
with failure with that it it engenders a
much better relationship with failure
yeah because it's not identity level
yeah the jokes of the bullets I'm the
gun like easy come easy go yeah so you
you let go of it you know but also when
you're doing something creative you got
to kill a lot of
babies they're all very precious to you
and you think they're fa it's a fabulous
little idea and that's nothing audience
just stared at you okay
the next one yeah that was swinging a
Miss yeah great but that isn't that kind
of a nice attitude for it's hard though
when you've made something that's you if
it's a movie or a a book that you've
worked on for years but that super smart
uh guy trying every chapter as he goes
along that's super smart yeah low stakes
low pressure creativity is something I
wonder whether it's played into by this
sort of concretizing of every thing that
you've ever
said throughout all of time being there
that it doesn't feel like the ephemeral
can be ephemeral anymore you can't just
blast it out it's iPhones at a comedy
show are kind of the enemy of creativity
censorship is not a problem in
comedy self-censorship is a huge problem
people not saying the unsayable risky
thing that could be the funniest [__]
[__] because they're worried well if
that's taken out of context what if
people don't understand I mean like why
do people like comedy there's a lot of
nuance in comedy isn't there there's no
Nuance in the modern world there's no
Nuance in in you know what's reported in
the media it's all a weird newsp and
then in comedy it's like you can say the
craziest [__] and people know it's not
yeah there's no hate in his heart just
fun did you see uh Roseanne get popped
for that little bit she did with theovon
she was making a joke about the Jews and
she basically said that not enough of
them were she she was
it was the most probably the most
egregious clipping of a bit yeah I
didn't see it so I can't really comment
but the idea of like the bad faith
argument that journalists make of going
I know it's a joke it was in a comedy
show at a comedy club that's the context
it was a joke and they go okay well
let's report it as if it was a statement
that was made ladies and gentlemen can I
get your attention make comment here
about no no one said
that she' made a bunch
of
obviously sarcastic very
over-the-top opposite statements it was
like and the pigs will fly and the sky
is green and the D D D D du basically
for for ages and ages and ages and ages
and ages and then at the very end said
like and not enough Jews su su suming it
was part of it was an ever escalating
statement about the Ridiculousness of
some of the claims that were being made
with some some something and they just
took the bit at the end yeah and I was
like come on you know I'm all for saying
you know this needs to be able to stand
up on its own like we things can be
taken in a little bit of isolation but
not that much
isolation yeah it is interesting though
isn't it the idea of you go well you
could take anything out of context and
someone's going to be upset as well also
you've got how much access to people now
everyone's got to say it used to be that
would have been an eye roll and a touch
from someone right someone said that not
for me thank you won't be buying a
ticket I won't go and now it's the the
idea of saying I don't like that seems
very reasonable to me no one should have
access to that seems like a different
thing so you know the free speech thing
is you go well until we find a better
system we have to have free speech what
about the Chinese system that's a good
system yeah I mean I mean that's the
world we could be living in you know
where I mean it's you know Charlie
Brooke has a mate of mine and those kind
of black mirrors where people are
getting so social points and then it's
happened I it's happening right now it's
unbelievable it's
like 1984 is happening right now you
know that they've got in China Gate
analysis that can work out even face
covered wearing clothes can work out who
someone is with about 90% plus accuracy
just from the way that they walk so
hiding your face hiding everything
dressing differently doing whatever
isn't sufficient to protect you now
they've fingerprinted your uh yeah
movement it's interesting that thing of
like the micro the macro so you can't
move privately but I think maybe with
social media now you can't think
privately because everything's um it
becomes slightly performative
and there's no
boredom you're constantly stimulated I
think we're slightly over stimulated as
a society like being bored is really
good for
creativity being a bit bored and a bit
like listless you know sometimes I look
even now it happens but it used to
happen more previously at how many
things I'll be doing at once so I'll be
replying to an email whilst I'm waiting
for the cattle to boil I'll be setting
the dishwasher away whilst listening to
a podcast at two times speed
and I'll be waiting for somebody I'm
like I've got like I'm literally waiting
for five things to happen doing three
that's the modern condition though isn't
it that you're you're so uh addicted to
activity to doing something and feeling
like you're being productive and
actually just letting yourself kind of
sit having some time just to think it's
the Charlie Monga thing isn't it the
idea of waiting and just having time
just to think and do
nothing read stuff every every single
morning for over 3 years now I have
started my day the exact same way which
is with element in water element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium pottassium and magnesium
and it is the best hydration drink that
I've ever found it tastes fantastic it's
super refreshing orange is just the most
OP flavor in the world it's absolutely
phenomenal and it helps to play a
critical role in reducing muscle cramps
and fatigue regulates your appetite it
optimizes brain health and it helps curb
Cravings they're also the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and relied on by tons of
Olympic athletes and everyday High
performers all around the world also
there is a no BS no questions asked
refund policy where you can buy a box
completely risk-free and if you do not
like it for any reason they will give
you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you love it element are giving
away a free sample pack of all eight
flavors with your first box if you go to
the link in the description box below or
drink LM nt.com
MW that drink LM nt.com
/mw thank you very much for tuning in if
you enjoyed that clip with Jimmy press
here for the fulllength 2 and 1 half
hour podcast episode you don't want to
miss it go
on